if you're looking to buy a new Macbook
it has probably never been this
confusing to figure out which one you
should buy especially now that the chips
have been upgraded to empty Pro and M2
Max and Apple has just released the new
15-inch MacBook Air which is way more
affordable if you want a larger display
but once you upgrade it the price shoots
way up but don't worry I can guarantee
you that if you stick through this video
till the end you'll know exactly which
MacBook is right for you but before we
get into explaining all of the
differences between these MacBooks I've
got to talk about the prices for each
one in the lineup starting with the M1
air this is the oldest one which retails
for a thousand dollars but you can find
it on sale on Amazon right now for as
low as 750 bucks then we have the
redesigned M2 air which has just gotten
a price reduction down to 10.99 but I've
seen it as low as 899 bucks the M2 macro
retails at 1300 the 14 inch pro is at 2
000 and the 16 inch at 2500 but once
again there are much better prices that
you get if you use the links down in the
video description now getting into the
differences the first thing I want to
discuss is the design and portability
the new redesigned M2 MacBook gear is by
far the fittest of them all and the most
portable in terms of footprint being
quite similar to the M1 MacBook Air on
the other hand the 16-inch MacBook Pro
is massive in comparison the only laptop
here that actually got thicker compared
to the previous generation this thing
weighs 4.8 pounds about 78 heavier than
the M2 air but the one that feels the
lightest is the 15 inch air because of
its large size but super thin design
that is only slightly heavier than its
13 inch version because of that it
really stands out in this lineup because
you get a large screen but a super thin
and lightweight design and with that
said the original M1 air just doesn't
kind of compare to the other ones with
its old design and the fact that you
miss out on macsafe and fast charging
now moving on to the keyboards and the
track pads they are all very similar
with the newer style of magic keys which
are all very nice however the M2 13-inch
MacBook Pro is the only one that still
has a touch bar which I personally don't
really like because I prefer having
those physical function keys and of
course all of them have Touch ID built
in now as far as the trackpads they are
all basically the same with the larger
models just having larger versions but
they're all for such and they all work
very well way better than Windows
laptops now no matter which Mac you buy
you need our sponsors really useful app
clean my Mac X to protect optimize and
clean your Mac I have used it for four
years now because of how simple but
powerful it is and they are constantly
improving it recently releasing the moon
lock engine which detects malware up to
two times faster and it even works with
external drives browser extensions
attachments and archives and this is the
second most used portion of of the app
clean my Mac X also deletes files
quickly and automatically including
hidden leftover junk files and the lens
tool helped me find and delete a
forgotten 55 gigabyte backup that was
just wasting space it can also update
apps clean up cache monitor health and
protect from Trojans data minders and
recent browser hijackers I also love the
menu app which helps to monitor your
devices and performance and if your Mac
feels slow just hit the free up memory
button check out all the functions with
a 7 day free trial or buy it for 20 off
for the next two weeks using the link in
the description in terms of ports all of
the lower price Macs come with two
thunderbol ports and a headphone jack
while the newer M2 models support High
impedance headphones and only the M2
airs come with that magsafe 3 Port which
matters because it frees up one of the
Thunderbolt ports to be used instead of
having to use that for charging on the
other end both 14 and 16 inch models
come with three Thunderbolt 4 ports
which means that they could support
multiple external displays up to two
with the M2 Pro and four with the M2 Max
and they are also the only ones that
support High refresh rates and up to 8K
resolution the regular M1 and M2 chips
only support a single external display
and they also lack an HDMI port and
those things could be one of the biggest
limitations for people and you also miss
out on that SD card slot moving on to
displays there are a lot of differences
to talk about but one of the biggest
ones is the Notch and notchless design
as well as the thinner bezels and as you
can see the M1 and M2 13-inch Pro have
that old design so they don't come at
that Notch which also means that they
only come with a 720p webcam compared to
1080p on the redesigned models take a
look at the video and Micron quality
differences in this comparison this is
the M1 MacBook airs 720p webcam quality
this is the M2 MacBook airs 1080p video
quality this is the M2 MacBook Pros 720p
webcam quality this is the 15 inch
MacBook airs 1080p video quality this is
a 14 inch MacBook Pros video quality and
this is the 16 inch MacBook Pro's video
quality now in terms of the actual knits
or brightness of the displays the M2 Pro
and the M2 airs have 500 nits while the
older M1 comes with only 400 so their
flexions can be slightly more noticeable
now all of these have pretty good color
support with P3 wide colors however the
14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros come with
much better mini LED displays compared
to the conventional LCDs which can
actually go up to a peak 1600 nits or a
thousand it's sustained across the
entire screen with a white page for
hours and hours on end this makes a big
difference when watching HDR videos
especially at night where the regular
lcd's black levels look great and you
definitely need the mini LED display if
you are editing HDR content now for
normal use you are still locked in at
500 nits unless you download the Vivid
app to unlock it making it much easier
to use Outdoors or in bright rooms the
other way that the 14 and 16 inch
standout is pro motion which gives you
smooth 120 hertz refresh rates but to me
that is not a deal breaker now let's
talk about the speaker quality the M2
air did get a new speaker system with
four speakers but to be honest it
doesn't sound that much better than the
M2 Pro or the M1 air in fact some people
still think the M1 air sounds better and
that might be because there are no
longer speaker grilles on the M2 air
because it got smaller now the new
15-inch has six speakers packed inside
just like the 14 and 16 inch laptops and
it is a good improvement over the
smaller laptops but it still can't
compete with the volume and base of the
thicker Pros go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
in terms of real world mixed battery
life the M2 MacBook Pro is going to give
you the best performance because of its
large battery the efficient chip and the
small display but the 15 inch air and
the 16-inch Pro are just slightly behind
the only one that could be slightly
disappointing is the 14 inch probe
because of its performance to battery
size ratio which takes a hit if you
start pushing it but remember any of
these laptops with macsafe could charge
to 50 in just 30 minutes and now let's
talk about the CPU and graphics
performance the M1 air is the only one
with the lower single core performance
but in the real world for simple tasks
you don't really notice it even for
tougher web-based applications like
figma the empty MacBook Air was super
smooth in our project divided by 500
designs which is one of the best design
suits in California is zoomed in nice
and smooth and then exporting 12
high-resolution web pages the results
end up not being as big of a difference
as you would expect now if you're doing
a lot of cpu-based productivity work
then the 14 and 16 inch macro Pros with
the M2 Pro and M2 Max ships are going to
be the best options however for the
majority of people the M2 Pro is more
than fast enough and even the M2 Chip is
more than enough for even some heavier
tasks now one thing I have to point out
is that even though the fanless MacBook
airs do great in normal tasks if you're
going to push them hard to their limits
for a constant 5 to 10 minutes you will
lose 15 to 20 percent of your
performance compared to the M2 13-inch
MacBook Pro which has a fan and can
maintain its performance now if you
combine really heavy CPU loads with
really heavy Graphics loads for say 20
minutes or so the perform performance
loss can become even greater and at the
same time this is where the 14 and 6
inch MacBooks push even further ahead
because of their dual fans and Powerful
Graphics especially the 16-inch M2 Max
so as you see if you can really push
your system spending the extra money is
well worth it not even counting the
other benefits but most people aren't
going to be pushing it this hard unless
they're doing this professionally
looking at graphics performance alone
the jump from M1 air to 13-inch M2 air
is substantial and the 14 inch pro also
has a great boost especially considering
the performance is consistent now the
base 14 inch M2 Pro can be upgraded to
19 core Graphics to match the 16 inch
performance and even to the M2 Max but I
personally would not recommend a 14 inch
with M2 Max because of the smaller size
the battery life will be really low and
it won't perform as well as a 16 inch
because it gets quite hot I also want to
point out that all of the M2 Series
Laptops have ssds that are half the
speed in their base capacity so an M1
airs 256 gig will be about twice as fast
as a 256 gig M2 air or Pro and this
could lead to lower performance for
large transfers or if you're doing a ton
of multitasking where your RAM is full
now this has really helped if you
upgrade to 16 gigs of RAM or if you
upgrade to 512 gigs of SSD on the 14 and
16 inch MacBooks the base 512s are also
half the speed compared to the one
terabyte and higher models but since
they are already so fast it is not as
big of a deal to make choices based on
performance simple if you care about it
I would skip the M1 air and for most
people doing normal productivity and
even some photo and video editing the M2
series is great with 16 gigs of RAM
being a nice upgrade and the 15 inch air
giving you more real estate if you
really need to push your system with
tough apps and you make a living doing
so so a 14 or 16 inches absolutely worth
it and honestly almost no one needs the
Mt Max unless you do raw video editing
or 3D Graphics or something where you
know that all the graphics power is
actually going to be used instead of
just sitting there untouched now if you
guys want to dive deep into Performance
Based on a variety of real world
applications and you are having a tough
time choosing between two of these
MacBooks we have a ton of head-to-head
real world comparisons that you can find
on our Channel where you just search it
up in YouTube so to summarize the M1 air
is perfect for those looking to get into
the Apple ecosystem getting an Apple
laptop as cheaply as possible and if
they're using it for basic tasks while
the M2 MacBook Air is for those who want
their fresh redesign the better display
and magsafe and with a 15 inch model
giving you a big screen without costing
a fortune now the M2 13-inch MacBook Pro
is for those who need a fan for extended
workloads but can't stretch their budget
it to the 14 inch model now the 14 inch
MacBook Pro is the best value for
productivity work while being Compact
and I think this might be the best
seller overall if you get my performance
while the 16 inch MacBook Pro is for
those who need a larger display with
additional features that the 15 inch air
doesn't offer once again we have Amazon
links to Big discounts on these MacBooks
down in the description below and you
can still add Apple care afterwards on
your Mac so don't worry about that go
ahead and click that Circle above to
subscribe and check out one of those
great videos right over there this has
been Max and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]